good morning Hank it's Tuesday today's
video is like the human heart and
barbershop quartet harmonies it comes to
you in four parts part one the holidays
Hank here in the United States there are
several holidays coming up and this year
both Christmas Eve and New Year's Eve
fall on Tuesdays and I will be taking
both those days off part two related
I've been thinking about burnout a lot
lately I'm not really burnt out at the
moment but I am starting to think
differently about the role work plays in
my life
ever since I was about 22 I've worked
many nights and most weekends I don't
recommend working that way and I don't
need to but I've continued to do it
anyway my central goal for the next
decade is to do fewer things that the
world constructs as work and more things
that are valuable but not usually
imagined as work like spending time with
family and doing the dishes and sleeping
and reading and volunteering my time and
talents to cause as I care about I'm
just saying that out loud in the hopes
that it will make me accountable part
three the project for awesome so Hank
back in 2007 when we first came up with
the idea for the foundation to decrease
worldsuck it was mostly a joke like we
decreased worldsuck by paying for people
to go to their first concerts which is a
value add to the universe I think but
maybe not the most efficient one
but then the project for awesome started
to grow and the foundation to decrease
worldsuck became a real charity that can
accept tax-deductible donations despite
its very silly name and last year the
project for awesome raised its ten
millionth dollar for charity the p4a is
my favorite time of the year and I can't
wait for the strange mix of exhaustion
and exhilaration it brings the 13th
annual how is that possible project for
awesome will happen this year between
noon Eastern Time on Friday December 6th
and noon Eastern Time on Sunday December
8th
but the IndieGoGo will launch this year
on December 3rd there will be many
amazing perks available more on those
next week and because the project for
awesome is a volunteer run organization
except for credit card fees and the cost
of making and shipping physical perks
all donations go to charity as in past
years during the first half of the
project for awesome we'll be raising
money for pre selected charities Save
the Children and Partners in Health both
of which our community has worked with
for over a decade and both of which have
excellent reputations for reaching and
assisting the most vulnerable people in
the world I should mention that this
year's p4a fundraising will be entirely
separate from the project we announced a
couple months ago with partners in
health Sierra Leone over 3,000 of you
have joined us in donating to support
the strengthening of
health care system and we are so
grateful and excited to watch that
progress over the next several years but
during this year's p4a as in past years
we're raising so-called unrestricted
funds which allows PIH and Save the
Children to spend the money wherever
it's most needed partners in health for
instance might need money to support a
clinic in the Navajo Nation or to buy
medical supplies in Haiti they know
better than we do where the funding gaps
are and unrestricted funds are really
important to charities so we're keeping
the Sierra Leone project separate if you
have any questions about this or about
anything please leave them in the
comments it occurs to me that someday
YouTube will probably move the comment
section to like a sidebar and then it
will look to people like I'm just
pointing at my pants and then it occurs
to me that someday YouTube will not
exist at all but back to the project for
awesome right okay so during the second
half of the project for awesome as in
past years we will be raising money for
charities chosen by you you make a great
video in support of a charity you think
deserves a grant and then upload it on
Friday December 6th and if people vote
for it at projectforawesome.com that
charity might receive part of the funds
raised during the second half of the
project for awesome so we're counting on
you to make great videos and pick worthy
charities all right let's talk about
money Hank and I will be matching the
first 150,000 dollars raised in this
year's project for awesome and I know
lots of you have donated to lots of
causes so really no pressure but if you
would like to join that matching fund
you can email us at FTD WS at complexly
comm that email address is also in the
doobly-doo and in the comments below if
you are able to join the matching fund
you will be thanked profusely and it
really does help drive donations ok part
4 for making it to the end of an update
video you win a picture of my brother
and me as reindeer one of the amazing
months of the 2020 project for awesome
calendar Rudolph I'll see you on Friday